the position of a particle moving along
a number line is given by s of T is
equal to two-thirds T to the third minus
6t squared plus 10t for T is greater
than or equal to 0 where T is time in
seconds the particle moves both left and
right in the first six seconds what is
the total distance traveled by the
particle four zero is less than or equal
to T is less than or equal to six
so let's just remind ourselves what they
mean by total distance if I were to say
start there and if I were to move three
units to the right and then I were to
move four units to the left and four
units to the left I don't say negative
four to show that I'm moving to the left
then my total distance right over here
is the total distance right over here is
seven three to the right and four to the
left even though my position right over
here is going to be negative one so my
position right over here is negative one
or you could say my net my net distance
or you could say my displacement is
negative one I'm one to the left of
where I started the total distance is
seven so now that we've clarified that I
encourage you to now pause this video
and try to answer the question what is
the total distance traveled by the
particle in these first six seconds so
we the the easiest way I can think of
addressing this is to think about well
what is this thing moving to the right
and when is it moving to the left it's
going to be moving to the right when the
velocity is positive and it's going to
be moving to the left when the velocity
is negative so this really boils down to
thinking about when is the velocity
positive or negative and to think about
that let's actually graph the velocity
function or make a rough sketch of it so
this is the position function the
velocity function is going to be the
derivative of the position function with
respect to time so derivative of two
thirds t to the third is going to be two
T squared and then we have minus 12t
plus ten and so let's just try to graph
this let's just try to graph this so
it's going to be an upward-opening
parabola this is clearly a quadratic and
the coefficient on the second degree
term on the t squared term is a positive
number so it's going to be an
upward-opening parabola is going to look
something like this and we're assuming
that it switches directions so it's
going to be positive
some of the time a negative for some of
the time so it should intersect the T it
should intersect the T axis where it's
negative the function is going to be
negative in that interval and it's going
to be positive outside of that interval
so the easiest thing I can think of
doing is let's try to find what the
zeros are and then we could draw this
upward opening parabola so to find its
zeros let's just set this thing equal to
0 so we get 2t squared minus 12t plus 10
is equal to zero divide both sides by
two just to get rid of this to make this
leading coefficient of one we get T
squared minus 6t plus five is equal to
zero that made a lot easier to factor
this can be factored into t minus one
times t minus 5 negative 1 times
negative 5 is 5 negative 1 plus negative
5 is negative 6 this is equal to 0 so
this left-hand side of the expression is
going to be equal to 0 if either one of
these things is equal to 0 take the
product of two things equaling 0 well
you get 0 if either one of them is 0 so
either T is equal to 1 or T is equal to
5 so now let's graph it so if I let's
draw our axes so that's my I could say
that's my velocity axis and let me draw
them we only care for positive values of
time so let's draw it something like
this positive time and let's see let's
take that 1 2 3 4 5 keep going so this
is T equals 1 this is T is equal to 5
this is our T axis and let's graph it so
it's going to be an upward-opening
parabola it's going to intersect both of
these points and so its vertex is going
to be when T is equal to 3 right in
between those points so it's going to
look something like this it's going to
look something like this that's the only
way to make an upward-opening parabola
that intersects the T axis at both of
these points at both of those points so
it'll go like that and it'll go like
this it'll intersect when T equals 0 we
actually can figure out when T equals 0
our velocity is 10 so this the V
intercept we could say is 10 right over
here so that's what it looks like so we
see that the velocity is positive
we see that the velocity is positive for
time between zero and one and it's also
positive for time is greater than five
seconds and we see that our velocity is
negative or that we're moving to the
left we're moving to the left between
one and five seconds the velocity is
below the T axis right over here it is a
negative so let's just think about what
our position is at each of these points
at time zero at time one at time five
and what we care about times six and two
times six and then think about how what
the distance it would have had to travel
between those times so let's think about
it so let's make a little table here
let's see what make it look make a
little table so this is time and this is
our position at that time so we care
about time zero time one time five
seconds and times six seconds so at zero
seconds we know that our position is
zero s of zero is a zero at one second
this is going to be 2/3 minus six plus
10 so it's going to be four and two
thirds so I'll write down four and two
thirds at five seconds let's see it's
two thirds times I'm gonna have to write
this one down so this is going to be two
thirds times 125 that's the same thing
as 250 over three that's the same thing
as 250 over three which is the same
thing let's see 250 over three that's
the same eighty-three times three is 249
so this is two four this is 83 and 1/3
so this is 83 and 1/3 that's this first
term minus six times -6 times 25 minus 6
times 25 so that's going to be minus 150
- 150 plus 10 times 5 so plus 50 so this
is going to simplify minus 150 plus 50
that's going to be minus 100 minus 180 3
and 1/3 mine
100 that's going to be negative 16 and
2/3 so negative 16 and 2/3 is this
position after 5 seconds and then at the
6 at 6 seconds it's going to be 2/3
times 6 to the 3rd let's write this one
down 2/3 times 6 to the 3rd 2/3 times 6
to the 3rd minus 6 times 6 squared well
that's just going to be that's going to
be that's going to be minus 6 to the 3rd
again 6 times 6 squared plus 60 and
let's see how can we simplify this right
over here well we could this part right
over here we can rewrite as we could
factor out a 6 to the third this is 6 to
the 3rd times 2/3 minus 1 plus 60 scroll
down a little bit get some more space so
there's going to be 6 to the 3rd times
negative 1/3 plus 60 and let's see this
is 6 let's write it this way this is
going to be 6 squared times 6 times
negative 1/3 plus 60 this right over
here is negative 2 so it's negative 2
times 36 this is negative 72 plus 60 so
this is going to be negative 12 so this
is going to be negative 12 right over
there so now we just think how far did
it travel well it starts traveling to
the right it's going to travel to the
right 4 and 2/3 so let's write this down
so we're going to have 4 and 2/3 and
then it's going to travel to the left
let's see to go from 4 and 2/3 to
negative 16 and 2/3
that means you traveled 4 and 2/3 again
you traveled 4 and 2/3 to the left and
then you travel another 16 and 2/3 to
the left another 16 and 2/3 left just a
reminder we're 4 and 2/3 to the right
now we have to go four and 2/3 to the
left get it back to the origin then we
have to go 16 and 2/3 again to the left
so that's why this move from here to
here is going to be 4 and 2/3 to the
left followed by 16 and 2/3 to the left
another way to think about it the
difference between these two points is
is what it's going to be 4 and 2/3 plus
16 and 2/3 if you do 4 and 2/3 minus
negative 16 and 2/3 you're going to add
that's the same thing as 4 and 2/3 plus
16 and 2/3 and then and then to go from
negative 16 and 2/3 to negative 12 that
means you went another 4 and 2/3 now to
the right so now this is 4 and 2/3 now
you're moving 4 and 2/3 to the right and
so we just have to add up all of these
we just have to add up all of these
values so what is this going to be so
this is going to be 2/3 times 4 which is
so the this part of it right over here
the fraction part of it 2/3 times 4 is 8
over 3 and let's see 4 plus 4 plus 16
plus 4 is 28 so 28 and 8/3 it's a very
strange way to write it because 8/3 is
the same thing as 8/3 is the same thing
as 2 and 2/3 so 28 plus 2 and 2/3 is 30
and 2/3 so the total distance traveled
over those six seconds is 30 and 2 30
and 2/3 units